hello every money body everybody
I love mornings in the park the light
through the trees the birds and the
squirrels statue I love hot lips turtle
head day morning graffiti removal week
oh I do love that I should get going
who's my special boy me daddy can't just
stick him back up there huh
I hate that part it's just a patch of
dirt and weeds and we're gonna buy it
we're gonna do the biggest real estate
deal in the history of the world
quick question over here Betsy are you
wearing a dog it's perfectly normal
I'm not gonna lie it's a little
distracting someone needs to protect the
park it's impossible it's impossible did
your voice just get really weird Sandro
how many time did you Jackson what would
you say is normal choice oh no no no no
[Applause]
he's fine
throw this see if you can get it into
the park hey did you get it right where
I wanted it where else can your son and
daughters give us a quick strike one for
Mama come on
are we dancing yeah we're dancing is
that dancing got a knock these bozos
wieners off central
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good luck managing the park that's gonna
go great for you what's that supposed to
mean
nerd
you
you